hello there welcome once again to our
show still taking place inside this
white void honestly I've been calling it
a white void but it's actually just this
zoomed in picture of Snoopy's dick yeah
for three weeks now you've been staring
a cartoon dog's dong sorry for not
telling you sooner but hey I'm telling
you now it's clearly been a very busy
week Bernie Sanders dropped out of the
presidential race
Boris Johnson dropped in then out of
intensive care and the corona virus
continued to cause widespread havoc
including forcing some of us to deal
with the difficulties of working at home
as this local news reporter learned when
his cat pulled focus during a live shot
another valley business is making
changes to ensure the customer and
worker safety starting today a White
House fruit farm in Canfield is
temporarily closing to walk in traffic
due to the corona virus pandemic I was
and this is true not paying attention to
a single word that man just said
probably because he broke the cardinal
rule of broadcast journalism never
report the news while sitting next to a
cat who's making a five-course meal out
of its own
I hope the story that he was trying to
break there was about how his cat's
butthole is clean as a whistle because
that's all the information I got from
that that clip actually points to our
main story though tonight which is how
the corona virus has impacted workers
not so much those who are lucky enough
like that man and that cat and our staff
to be able to work from home that's
something only around a third of people
are able to do in this country instead
I'd like to talk about two groups the
unemployed and those currently having to
leave the house because they work
essential jobs because each is facing a
different set of challenges and let's
start with the unemployed more than one
in 10 workers have lost their jobs in
the past three weeks
those are staggering numbers and the
federal government has taken some big
steps to protect those people and to try
and slow down job loss unfortunately the
execution has been less than ideal take
the Paycheck protection program which
offers loans of up to ten million
dollars to small businesses loans which
don't have to be repaid if they keep
their workers on the payroll to here
Trump tell it the rollout has been
pretty great it's really a tribute to
government really well-run government
and there are few glitches very few and
a little glitch we had worked out within
minutes within hours I just want to
congratulate everybody who's become so
popular that is just classic Trump to
try and brag about how in demand an
emergency bailout system is if he was
captain of the Titanic you just know
he'd be saying I just want to
congratulate everyone these lifeboats
have become so popular a few weeks ago
nothing now they're moving like hotcakes
it's really a tribute to a well-run ship
and I know this won't shock you but the
situation the president just said was
going great and makes him look good
isn't and doesn't because the glitches
he just tried to brush off were pretty
substantial of the day the program was
supposed to launch many of the nation's
biggest banks said they weren't yet
ready to take loan applications because
the government didn't release final
versions of the documents they needed
until the night before this means may
banks have been playing catch-up as this
health food store owner discovered
Monday morning I go into my branch the
talk to my my banker he didn't know what
was going on he wasn't even informed so
he couldn't even reform us to apply
because he didn't know is it frustrating
for you when you're hearing no no the
SBA is gonna get involved and they are
going to provide a safety net but when
that's the question that's the
million-dollar question yeah of course
it is whether you're a small business
owner or a trapeze artist the two
questions you always want answered about
your safety net or when will it be there
and how bigger the holes and the obvious
problem is if help takes months to come
that's not going to save a business set
to go under in weeks now to be fair no
program of this size was ever going to
have a perfect rollout but this is yet
another area where this administration
could have been preparing for this much
much sooner and it definitely doesn't
help that the director of the National
Economic Council Larry Kudlow downplayed
complaints like this my wife Julie whom
you know
and she is a self-employed artist
painter a very distinguished one some
renown she could use some help for her
operation and she went to a local
community bank up in our place in
Connecticut and apparently it's just a
one-page form that's all it is so
couldn't be easier
yeah his response was basically my wife
did it so what's the problem well there
are a few issues there one Judy Kudlow
is the wife of a high-ranking White
House official which might have had some
impact on her experience at the bank -
I'm not sure the phrase it couldn't be
easier should apply to anyone whose
situation includes
being married to Larry Kudlow and three
if your ears perked up when you heard
him say his wife is an artist of some
renown you're not alone we did look into
it so you might want to lace up some
comfy shoes because we're about to go
for a brief walk together through Judith
Carlos still life work it often seems to
be focused on her husband's clothes
that's a real painting titled
three shirts showcasing what I can only
assume are three of Larry's shirts and
that's just part of a larger collection
in her closet series featuring such
pieces as summer shirt gray and white
American shirts and American shirts 2013
but I don't want you to think her art is
merely shirt based she also paints her
husband's ties like lots and lots and
lots of his ties just when you think she
couldn't possibly paint another of larry
cudlow ties she does it again and then
somehow does it again and then again and
again and again and crucially larry
cudlow himself appears to be nowhere in
her work and i don't mean to make any
sweeping judgments about their marriage
i'm just saying these aren't so much
portraits of larry cudlow as they are
portraits of the absence of larry cudlow
they showcase the beauty of where larry
cudlow isn't and sure that's a beauty we
can all appreciate I mean it's no stay
up late by Brian Swords of York but what
is and on that note I actually have
another proposition if you are the owner
of a Judith
loti painting I want one you may
remember I offered to buy $1,000 for
stay up late which is why I'm willing to
offer $10 for one of these although
that's not all as this offer also comes
with a $20,000 donation to the food bank
in your area so if you or someone you
know owns one of these la realist
masterpieces just email John at John
Oliver once your rat erotica com there
was no needs to make up a new email
address when the perfect one was already
available anyway what we're talking
about that's right
mass unemployment with the Paycheck
protection program experiencing a bumpy
rollout and thousands of businesses
laying off staff millions and now in
need of government assistance that is
why Congress has significantly expanded
unemployment insurance for the next few
months which is good unfortunately the
sheer magnitude of demand combined with
the fact many states on employment
systems have been neglected and
underfunded for decades means that too
often people having real difficulty
getting through all specialists are busy
with other customers you must hold back
this weed I've done that 50 times every
day for two weeks
are you a month away from being broke
two months away I'd say about a month
yeah you know I'm curious would you try
the unemployment office again yeah
absolutely
[Music]
we're sorry you're experiencing an
extremely high volume of calls at this
time holy with those results you
might as well call seven one nine two
six six two eight three seven it's the
calling Oats hotline an actual number
you can dial to hear one of four
possible Hall & Oates songs in an
emergency now sure they can't help you
with your health care or finances but
honestly neither can the Department of
Labor right now and at least with Colin
Oates
you get to hear maneater so once again
if that's 7 1926 Oates so claiming
unemployment is incredibly difficult
right now and that's not even getting
into the fact that for many people who
lose their job
oops they then lose their healthy choice
and this is to put it mildly a very bad
time for that to be happening so it's
frankly no wonder many who can work feel
that they have to even if that means
enduring a dangerous work environment
and that brings us to the second group
we're going to look at tonight essential
workers it's a broad term that can
include any job from health care
professionals to custodians to grocery
store clerks to I would argue
tick tock stars teaching me how to dance
peril basket killed her husband whacked
can't convince me that it didn't happen
venom the Tigers they snack in what's
happening Carol basket excellent in the
Venn diagram of how I'm spending my time
during quarantine the absolute dead
center is the overlap of tick tock
learning a brand new skill and Tiger
king I'm gonna be such a good
dancer slash Carol Baskin truth or when
I get out of here or I should say Carol
Baskin and companies who employ
essential workers have openly wax poetic
about how much they value them few in
more glowing terms than Amazon to all of
our Hamazon retail heroes on the floor
in the air and behind the wheel we want
to thank you
we'll continue to do everything we can
to keep you healthy safe and protected
the work you are doing means everything
right now
thank you it's hard to say what I like
least about that maybe it's these
schmaltzy piano music maybe it's Amazon
patronizingly claiming they care about
the well-being of their heroes or maybe
it's just the fact that out of context
the Amazon smile logo is a quick sketch
of a circumcised dick it's probably a
combination of all three and while the
company claims it's keeping workers safe
by distributing masks and and conducting
temperature checks many Amazon workers
paint a much different picture citing
concerns like an inability to maintain
social distancing guidelines our lack of
protective gear and hand sanitizer
and lack of time to clean their hands
and if you feel you're not working in
safe conditions it can be even more
infuriating to know the items of your
packing can sometimes be anything but
essential they should not be selling
non-essential items if you go on the
website all the essential items are sold
out until you restock and until you
close this building shut it down dildos
are not essential items books for kids
yes but dildos no right risking your
life to get some what a sex toy probably
doesn't feel fair there's a reason 1917
wasn't about two soldiers trying to
bring benedict cumberbatch a dildo he
wanted although yes the cinematography
would still have been impressive the
continuous shot of George McCoy
sprinting through the trenches followed
by Benedict Cumberbatch masturbating
with a dildo to completion in Deacons
hands it would have been a masterpiece
and look determining what constitutes an
essential product clearly isn't
straightforward if dildos make it easier
for people to stay inside
you could argue they might literally
save lives but if we're depending on
those workers for both our survival and
to a certain extent our comfort we owe
them a lot in return and company should
be doing everything they can to lower
the risks to workers which can be
offering protective gear are changing
workflow to allow for more distance or
putting up
glass shields in grocery stores and one
thing every company should be doing is
offering paid sick leave Congress
actually required employers to
temporarily provide two weeks of that in
the family's first coronavirus response
act but unfortunately that requirement
only applies to businesses with fewer
than 500 employees the thinking was that
larger companies were either already
offering paid sick leave all would do it
on their own sadly that has not always
been the case BuzzFeed found that all
these companies currently have policies
less generous than the one that
government established for small
businesses or have set unreasonably high
bars to qualify for example Amazon's
initial policy was that it would give
two weeks paid time off that anyone
who's diagnosed with kovat or who's been
quarantined which sounds good but
there's a big problem with requiring a
positive test as one worker pointed out
good luck getting the test in the state
of New York right now this is very hard
to make appointments it's very hard we
the time you get to test it's days later
the time you get the results is days
later exactly testing in New York is so
scarce Amazon's plan may as well have
been you get double pay and free health
care for your whole family if you can
guess what number Jeff Bezos is thinking
that man's name is Chris smalls and he
was fired just two hours after he helped
organize an employee walkout in Amazon's
Staten Island facility last week
according to Amazon he was let go for
putting the health and safety of others
at risk by violating social distancing
guidelines and in order to quarantine
but leaks notes from an internal meeting
days later which Bezos himself was
present showed the company's leadership
discussing plans to make smalls the face
of the entire union organizing movement
since he is not smart or articulate
which holy
that is so racist I can't even point out
how smart and articulate smalls is
without also sounding racist and Amazon
will say they've now made their sick
leave policy more lenient for their
heroes which is true what's also true is
there only came after they got a letter
from 14 state attorneys general saying
their initial policy
was inadequate to protect the public
health and this clearly isn't just about
Amazon again many companies have chosen
not to offer paid sick leave possibly
because the u.s. is one of the few
wealthy democracies that does not
mandate that they do that and that does
a disservice not just to workers but
also to customers as this McDonald's
employee will tell you I worked at
McDonald's for over ten years on that
face that you see that I serves you your
hash brown for breakfast
maybe a quarter pounder for lunch and
even gave you a McFlurry to top off your
dinner menu so I ask you if I caught the
coronavirus would you want me making
your next meal no of course not I
wouldn't want anyone with the
coronavirus serving me my next meal
unless of course that person was Adam
driver because infecting me with dessert
is very much on my running list of
things Adam driver can do to me oh I'm
sorry
you thought I'd stop the Adam driver
because I'm stuck at home now you were
wrong about that and yes I know my wife
can hear me that part of it sneezing my
McFlurry you pensive bison ravaged my
lungs you relentless Hey look look
Congress absolutely needs to mandate all
businesses provide paid sick leave in a
next coronavirus aid bill on a permanent
basis as well as require they provide
significant hazard pay for any worker
being asked to risk their lives because
that risk is very very real grocery
store workers are dying of this disease
right now and so far we've lost 41
transit workers in New York City alone
and this is the least of what essential
workers and indeed all workers need
right now they need protection
financially physically and otherwise
because there are some truly
indefensible situations being thrown
into plain view
take this EMT in New York State who is
doing incredible dangerous work without
something you might assume he has right
now I'm doing all of this with no health
insurance how is that possible I doesn't
come through the job the job doesn't
offer it and our affordable marketplaces
aren't very
portable if I get sick and okay I go get
tested positive I can't go to the
hospital you know people come out and
they show us the support and I love it I
love I've eaten so much pizza in the
last two weeks it's been great
I don't need pizza I need to be able to
pay my bills I need to be able to work a
40-hour workweek and and live like a
normal human being yeah it's like that
old saying about pizza and sex even when
they're bad they're still pretty good
and even when they're really good he is
still need health care and
obviously his work should give him
health insurance but more broadly we
need to seriously think about whether
having our health insurance systems so
tied to employment is a good idea
because I would argue it emphatically
isn't in fact while many of the problems
were being forced to confront right now
weren't created by the coronavirus it
has thrown a spotlight on some of the
biggest flaws in how our system operates
things like paid sick leave and hazard
pay or essentially band-aids and we
absolutely need them right now because
we're bleeding but when this is over
this country is going to need more than
band-aids
it's gonna need surgery things
need to change and not go back to normal
control-z us back to how we were in 2016
is simply not going to cut it and
honestly it shouldn't have taken a
pandemic to prove our unemployment
system is a mess that we need universal
health care and that workers need
benefits the right to organize and wages
that reflect how essential they really
are and we also shouldn't have leads a
pandemic to consider whether mass
incarceration is tolerable as prisons
and jails become petri dishes for the
coronavirus or whether our treatment of
the homeless is adequate when we've seen
photos of them sleeping in a parking lot
six feet apart or what we do about the
multiple underlying inequalities that
are making this virus in some places
twice as deadly for black and Latino
people as whites
and must be infuriating is that some
conservatives have seemed worried that
we might do too much the extension of
paid sick leave opens the door you know
what's going to happen on the Democratic
side
sure
is gonna want a permanent program
they're gonna try to get another social
program out of this we can't let that
happen
really why the not that argument
basically boils down to well if we help
people today the Democrats are just
gonna want to help more people tomorrow
like that's a bad thing
and while dollar store bill nighy here
has moderated his stance since then
others are still adamant that nothing
should permanently change because of
this thora de senator Rick Scott seen
here having just learned that enough
money was raised at the talent show and
he won't be able to shut down the
orphanage after all he put out a
statement arguing that this crisis
shouldn't be an opportunity for members
of Congress to permanently expand the
welfare state which is weird because
there is no better argument for a
permanent welfare state than watching
your government desperately try to build
one when it's already too late because
make no mistake the real test here isn't
whether or not our country will get
through this it will the question is how
we get through this and what kind of
country we want to be on the other side
and if nothing else this crisis has done
what any great judeth Kudlow painting
does make painfully clear what we've
been missing all along
you